the golden Consulting rule which is walk
talk right so in the old times you were
told that usually should always try to
walk by a client to directly talk to
that person that's not possible you try
to talk to them on the phone for
instance just calling them and only if
this is not possible as well only then
you write to them but clearly now in the
times of working from home the walk
option is not not possible anymore and
also talking is more difficult because
you cannot have these more informal
conversations you will need to always
schedule a meeting book an appointment
to then jump on a video chat with one of
these people if this is what you want to
do